Leaders or the one smart enough to hire
people smarter than them,
but that's the first thing you do.
You've got to get four or five people
that are smarter than you guys have to
work together.
You guys have to,
you know,
start from the bottom,
think about all the good ideas and think
about all the bad ideas.
And if the good outweighs the bad,
then you should go with the bad.
Always good,
then you should probably think about
something else.
But that's always been my philosophy and
I have guys that are very intelligent,
very smart work for me with my ideas,
their intelligence,
my intelligence.
It's been working out pretty good so
far.
It's not a dictatorship,
uh,
act as a leader,
but I take input from everybody like,
Hey,
I don't think we should do this,
or hey,
I think it's a good idea.
So,
you know,
most of the time I am kind of voting
without going through the voting
process.
So let's just say it's five of us and
three says,
I don't think we should do it.
Says we should do it.
Probably won't do it.
But you know,
when you're on a team and you have to do
everything collaboratively and you know,
sometimes you're not going to get along
and sometimes you're going to have an
argument,
but the respect factor is always there
and uh,
you know,
as long as you respect each other,
treat everyone with respect and,
you know,
just listened to everybody's views.
It's okay.
You know,
one of my favorite books is the one
minute manager.
So,
you know,
when I'm listening to my guys,
first thing is I don't act like I know
at all.
So I hear suggestions,
I put it.
My suggestion is that we have a couple
meetings and then we just ironed it out
and we just figured it out.
I learn every day,
uh,
you know,
but no,
the good thing that's,
that has brought me along the way as I
know how to win championships.
I know how to build teams.
So I,
I have great teammates surrounding me.
And so,
you know,
anytime I get into a venture,
uh,
most of the time we know what we're
doing and if it's a problem,
we figured out as a team.